[Music]
foreign
hi everybody it is September 11th 2023
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
we are live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals uh you may have noticed we
did not cold open for you today we did
not throw it in today because it is the
anniversary of 9 11 I wanted to uh share
some thoughts up top uh as many of you
know and as I've written about uh I
lived in New York City during 9 11. uh
it's crazy I mean absolutely crazy to me
that 22 years have passed since then as
I mentioned on the show all the time at
least in my life the years seem to be
going by a lot faster lately maybe that
has something to do uh with fatherhood
I'm not sure it's just life seems to
just move and move and move the endless
scroll all of that stuff so we are gonna
do a normal show today but we're going
to kind of frame it around 9 11 maybe
some of the lessons uh that we did learn
that we should have learned that we
could have learned and how not to repeat
some of the mistakes that we've made in
the last 22 years because it does seem
like the country and and maybe the world
is kind of a little off its axis since
then so I wanted to start you know I was
like all right well what what can we
show of 9 11 and I have no doubt that uh
many of you that are on social media or
if you're watching cable news today you
know they show the planes crashing they
they show the horror afterwards all all
of the stuff but I wanted to show just
one moment and I think it was probably
the moment that America in many ways at
least related to 9 11 related to that
period of time
in American history when we actually
peaked because this was the World Series
this was President George W bush
throwing out the first pitch of game
three of the 2001 World Series which as
you may remember the World Series and
virtually all of our sporting events
cultural events Etc were delayed for a
series of times so this was the latest
starting World Series I think in the
history of baseball this is game three
of the 2001 World Series and just I mean
you will get chills up your spine no
matter how many times you've watched
this
for tonight
ceremonial first pitch
and please welcome
the president of the United States
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr President
thank you
and I mean still chills up my spine as I
said I lived in New York City during
that I I just want to mention one little
personal story about 9 11 and everyone
that lived in New York City or if you
lived in DC or really I mean if you were
alive in America that time you have some
story of what it was like for you on
that day you didn't have to live in the
exact spots that the attacks occurred to
to feel it obviously I lived on 90th and
1st in New York City which was that's
upper east side so in some ways it's
like polar opposite of where the Twin
Towers were from downtown Manhattan uh
you got 90 plus blocks between the two
and east side west side but I lived on
90th and 1st at the time and that's
about a block or two away from Gracie
Mansion which is the mayor's Mansion at
the time there was a re-election going
on for the mayor of New York City and I
was doing stand-up at night I was
working all sorts of odd jobs during the
day so I was getting up late and that
morning I had just got a cell phone I
remember it was a little Nokia remember
those little like brick black and white
cell phones I had just got cell phone so
that even that just talk about how time
changes so it's 2001 just got a cell
phone and my cell phone rang
and it was my dad and my dad worked in
Midtown Manhattan and his office
building faced downtown towards the
towers and he said that a plane had hit
did I see anything did I hear anything
was I watching the news that a plane had
hit one of the twin towers and I turned
on the TV and immediately and I'm
watching CNN and everything else and
then it was just you know we hung up the
phone no one realized it was an attack a
terrorist attack at the time and then
obviously a few minutes later the the
second plane hit and then the story that
I want to tell you because uh everyone
can tell you the story The Horror the
amount of people that died and I had
family members who were firefighters and
all sorts of stuff but I remember over
the next couple weeks in New York City
there was this this
unbelievably like it was this
unbelievably awful feeling and then also
like
an incredible feeling that started to
emerge of sort of Brotherhood and
decency you know people in New York City
like honking of horns was not happening
as much as screaming at each other all
of the stuff that we can kind of joke
about New York City back in the day
versus what now New York City has become
like the the heart of New York City
um it was it was ripped out and then it
was kind of rebuilding there was like
this new Brotherhood there anyway a few
weeks after 9 11's it's probably about
two weeks after in those first two weeks
everybody basically stayed at home
watching TV the entire time uh I had
friends that couldn't get out of the
city for a couple days that were working
in New York City that were staying with
us for a couple days my dad had a few of
his co-workers stay at my grandmother
who lived in New York City because they
couldn't get out of the city I mean
there was all sorts of craziness anyway
after 10 days or two weeks or so I
finally was like I have to get out of
the house I I out of the apartment I
gotta just like see what life is and I
remember uh you could still smell like
the soot and the
all of all of just the Carnage and the
smoke and everything you could still
smell it and again I'm 90 some odd
blocks away this is two weeks later but
I thought all right I'm gonna go play
basketball so I went by Gracie Mansion I
took my basketball and I went over to
the court just to like find some guys to
play pickup or I was just going to shoot
around or something and I get involved
in a game and we're playing and it's
weird it's weird it's like nobody's
talking nobody's trash talking it's just
like weird nobody knew if we even should
be there or it was just weird and uh
we're getting into it and then two guys
uh one guy goes up hard he gets hit by
the other guy and they get into each
other's faces and I kid you not I cannot
describe this properly
they were about to beat the out of
each other like you could see it
happening I can picture it in slow
motion they both started crying right in
front of each other and they like kind
of hugged and I don't even think they
knew each other and then everyone else
on the court like we all just kind of
were like all right everybody calm down
I don't know for some reason that
feeling that thing sticks out to me just
on a personal note I thought I would
share that I've shared that once or
twice over the years but I thought that
would be an interesting way uh to talk
about today's show because we are in all
of this together as crazy as it all is
and you like this candidate and I like
this candidate and the Democrats are
doing this and the Republicans are doing
this it's like if this experiment is
going to continue we are going to have
to figure out a way to get a little bit
of that decency that Brotherhood that
sense of you know oh this is a country
of different people and we're going to
make this thing work we got to get it
back it is going to be very difficult
because the entire machine as I often
talk about it is set up
to put us against each other it is set
up to have us in constant opposition and
angry at each other and angry at the
wrong people while it continues to
attain power and so now what I want to
do with the show today is talk about how
legitimate and illegitimate crises often
Advance the power that the machine has
right and so there were legitimate
crises let's say we get attacked like we
were attacked on 9 11 but then do we
maybe attack the wrong country after
that becomes illegiant illegitimate uh
from what's going on with Ukraine right
now to the sudden covid thing that we
seem to be bringing back to the system
wanting to push everyone into climate
change lockdowns so the whole idea of
the show today is the lessons that we
can learn from our our Post 9 11
response and we will end it I promise
you in an inspiring and positive way uh
before we get to all that let me talk to
you guys about Patriots apply it's kind
of the right sponsor for today's show uh
do you ever get the feeling that
something bad is about to happen well I
do between the distractions and smoke
screens in the media we probably won't
see it coming which is why it's smart to
invest in emergency food right away as
they say it's better to have it and not
need it than to need it and not have it
my Patriot Supply is the nation leader
in high quality emergency food head to
my website prepare with reuben.com and
you'll save 200 on your three-month
emergency food kit from my Patriot
Supply enjoy a wide variety of delicious
meals offering 2 000 over 2 000 calories
a day for Optimum strength under stress
stock up before Panic sets in free
shipping is automatic and your order
ships fast go to prepare with reuben.com
prepare with reuben.com and now back to
me okay so how can I do a show
on the anniversary of 9 11 without being
crazily partisan and adding to all of
the mess well I'm going to try it a very
sober way to talk about all of the
things happening right now and reflect
on some of the as I said earlier some of
the mistakes that we made that got us
into Wars and all of the craziness that
kind of leads us to the to the weirdness
that we're in right now okay so uh
what's the war happening right now well
it's this Ukraine war and it's a little
unclear sort of why we're in it how do
we get in it are we actually declaring
war no has Congress ever voted to
authorize war no are refunding or yes
does it seem like the machine wants to
ramp up that war yes so now I want to
show you two videos here uh this is
Anthony blinken and Mitch McConnell
pushing for more funding for the Ukraine
war these are both of these are just in
the last couple days
for Ukraine not only to survive but to
thrive we're also supporting its efforts
to rebuild from Russia's aggression
at the Ukraine recovery Conference held
in London a few months ago I pledge that
the United States would invest more than
520 million dollars in making Ukraine's
energy infrastructure more than half of
which has been destroyed by Russia
cleaner more resilient and more
integrated with Europe the president has
I think been too slow
to keep the commitments that he's made
publicly
but at least
he's supporting the effort I think he
could have done it more skillfully
but he is supporting the effort and I
intend to continue to support it and I
hope the majority of my colleagues will
feel the same way all right so what's
interesting about that is as I said I
was trying not to do Today's Show in a
hyper partisan way I try not to do that
in general but my feelings about things
are what they are but what I showed you
right there was the Democrat Secretary
of State we need more money more money
for Ukraine right I think it was 525
million we've given them billions but
more money for their energy sector blah
blah blah and then what is he in uh or
who's in agreement with him well it's
the Republican uh Majority Leader right
and he's in agreement yes more money I
wish Joe would do it faster we've just
got to pour more money into this and I
just want to ask you this if you're an
American watching this show does it seem
like your hard-earned tax money should
be going to funding this war that again
we have not declared as a war as if
America doesn't have enough problems on
on its own crumbling infrastructure we
don't protect our own border we see more
interested in protecting Ukraine's
border than our border I'm not even a
complete absolute isolationist I think
there are moments that you have to use
the military I believe in a strong
military mostly so that you don't have
to use it but this endless funding of
this of this thing that nobody really
knows what's going on does seem like a
problem and it does seem like a
particular problem when you think about
it from the context that for some reason
most of the Democrats and most of the
Republicans are into it
so now I'm going to segue to Woody
Harrelson oh I did that I don't know but
Woody Harrelson actor kind of comedian
pothead Woody Harrelson you may remember
this he was uh guest hosting Saturday
Night Live about six months ago we
showed you this video and I thought it
kind of framed what we're talking about
here quite well relative to the machine
always kind of getting what the machine
wants okay so the movie goes like this
the biggest drug cartels in the world
get together and buy up all the media
and all the politicians and force all
the people in the world stay locked in
their homes and people can only come out
if they take the cartels drugs and keep
taking them over and over
I threw the script away I mean who is
going to believe that crazy idea okay so
obviously what he's talking about there
is covid and vaccines and everything
else he goes on later to talk about how
the war machine does it and I will
connect that to how the war machine
after 9 11 lied us into Wars using the
politicians who were kind of just
puppets for the whole thing but now
speaking of covet uh well you might find
this interesting the U.S open was over
the weekend you might have heard about
that and uh guess who was uh advertising
and sponsoring the U.S open with their
shot of the day segment shot of the day
the ball of these people take a look
oh oh boy well we'll take you to the
modernist shot of the day and it was
saving the match point match point to
get to number 24. there were a lot of
shots that were highly impactful but
here's the final one
[Music]
another day at the office
relief and release there
[Music]
so the shot of the day brought to you by
moderna
shot of the day brought to you by
moderna like they're still doing it guys
right you'll see how I'm connecting this
to the war thing but they're still doing
it the shot of the day just like we've
shown you all those videos of Pfizer who
sponsors all of the media that you know
sort of the NPC people are watching
right you turn on CNN you turn on ABC
News NBC News and it's always brought to
you by Pfizer well the guy they showed
there during the shot of the day that
was Novak Djokovic and uh yeah he won
the U.S open so I thought we'd show you
that
[Applause]
24. that's who he is
foreign
twist guys novik Djokovic who now is
widely thought as the greatest tennis
player in the history of the sport 24
Grand Slam championships uh you may
remember that he was not allowed to
compete in the U.S for over two years he
was not allowed to compete in the
Australian Open a couple years ago
because yeah he is unfaxed so suck that
moderna you might remember this from
February of 22 this was a BBC reporter
asking him if it was worth it to not get
faxed I understand the consequences of
my decision and one of the consequences
of my decision was not going to
Australia and I was prepared not to go
and I understand that not being
vaccinated today I you know I'm unable
to travel to most of the tournaments at
the moment and that's the price you're
willing to pay that that is the price
that I'm willing to pay ultimately
are you prepared to forgo
the chance to be the greatest player
that ever picked up a racket
statistically
because you feel so strongly about this
Jab
yes
I do but as things stand if this means
that you miss the French Open
is that a price you'd be willing to pay
yes that is the prize that I'm willing
to pay and if it means that you miss
Wimbledon this year again that's a price
you're willing to pay yes
why Novak why why because the principles
of uh
decision making on my body are more
important than any title
or anything else I'm I'm trying to be in
tune with my body
um as much as I possibly can
I don't know who that journalist air
quotes journalist is but what a pathetic
embarrassing hack what a sycophant for
the machine and we know literally
hundreds of these types of people that
operate in mainstream media but what
what a beautiful answer I have some
autonomy over my body I will make
decisions for myself if you watch the
extended portion of the interview he
talks about his diet he talks about his
exercise regimen
um and guess what he turned out to be
right so how are our brilliant Sports
slash political analysts dealing with uh
Djokovic winning again this is Keith
olberman Now Keith olberman used to be
on ESPN when ESPN was great he was on
MSNBC he has completely lost his mind
this might be a little gratuitous but
here's what he said about Novak Djokovic
winning can we get this effing vaccine
needle phobic fraud Djokovic off my TV
and get to the baseball game like what
is genuinely like what is wrong with
these people at this point and vaccine
needle phobic well first off it has
become very very clear that the vaccines
certainly don't work as promised there's
a lot of evidence that they don't work
at all and now there's increasing
evidence that they are causing more
injuries than they than they were ever
repressing risk as it came related to
covid okay so what is wrong with these
people right why is it that they still
are pushing this stuff well they're also
pushing the craziness because they went
so deep in on it right if you were
demanding that people got fired from
their jobs if you were demanding that
kids have to wear masks in schools
because everything it's hard to get out
of that hole you just keep going and
going and going I I am very I don't know
what it is in me that or in all of the
craziness the crazier it got I think the
more I pushed against it and I'm
guessing that's probably at least partly
why you watch this watch this program uh
but you know the truth is coming out and
more and more people are realizing uh
that maybe they shouldn't have got the
vaccine I this one we saw last week I
wanted to get it on the show last week
it fits here perfectly
my friend and I would say colleague to
some extent she'll be on the show again
in a couple weeks uh Megyn Kelly has
just announced that she now has an
autoimmune issue which her doctor told
her is likely because of getting the
coveted vaccine
I regret getting the vaccine even though
I'm a 52 year old woman because I don't
think I needed it I think I would have
been fine I got covered many times and I
it was well passed when the vaccine was
doing what it was supposed to be doing
um and then for the first time I tested
positive for an autoimmune issue at my
annual physical and I asked I went to
the best rheumatologist in New York and
I asked her do you think this could have
to do with the fact that I got the damn
booster and then got covered within
three weeks and she said yes yes I
wasn't the only one she'd seen all right
so now does that make Megyn Kelly a
conspiracy theorist does it make her a
crazy person or a tin foil hat wearer or
any of that stuff she got a vaccine that
she kind of got coerced into as she's
saying like she didn't really feel like
she needed it she had already she did it
post finding out it was already a little
shady in the first place and now she has
this autoimmune issue I don't know
anything beyond that related to her
health but I certainly hope that she's
okay but we all know people like that I
know a guy in his early 20s who never
had heart issues who now has heart
issues I know two or three people that
are having shingles related things and
balancing related things and someone
having Vision related things all
post-vacs now where they all definitely
connected to vacs
I don't know I don't know but we were
sold a lie on this stuff and why do you
think so many people fell for it because
we get hit constantly every day with
this endless propaganda machine whether
it is either propaganda as it relates to
war which again I'm going to bring this
whole thing around I promise you or
whether it's vaccines or climate change
or anything else and and it happens so
fast now because of social media we
don't even notice the hypocrisy
here is Joe Biden in September of 21 and
Pfizer CEO Albert borla in January of 22
talking about vax efficacy and see if
you note the difference
I want to emphasize that the vaccines
provide very strong production
from severe illness from covet 19. the
two dose of a vaccine offer very limited
protection if any the three doses with a
booster they offer reasonable protection
so there you have it Joe Biden had no
idea what he was saying right he's just
reading it off a teleprompter right just
like in uh June of 21 when he said if
you get the vaccine you will not get nor
transmit covet he had no idea to say it
but he said it because he read off a
script because he basically is an actor
and not a particularly good one and then
you have the head of Pfizer who
originally said the vaccines work then
saying you need two and then you need
three and a booster blah blah and then
again they have no evidence whether this
basically saved anybody at this point
and yet the machine still the corporate
machine still puts these people on
television even this past weekend yeah
fauci the man should be in a cave
somewhere where no one will ever see him
again right I don't even think you have
to I don't think you have to put him in
jail I think there's reasons that you
probably could but how about just go to
a cave and disappear forever but instead
fauci is on ABC over the weekend pushing
the Pfizer backs I believe we should
give the choice to people who are not in
the high risk groups to have the vaccine
available for them because again we have
experience with this type of vaccine in
billions of people it's a safe vaccine
of course with the MRNA there's a very
very very low risk particularly in young
men of getting a myocarditis but if you
look at the risk of myocarditis from
covet itself is greater than the risk of
the vaccine okay and so from my own
personal standpoint yeah I would say
that make it available for everyone but
certainly recommended for the high-risk
people
I have to say Anthony about you if
you're watching this show thank God more
and more people are tuning you out I get
it they'll put you on corporate press
they'll keep putting you up there I
believe we should give the choice well
no one's saying there shouldn't be a
choice I suppose there are some people
who should say we should Outlaw these
vaccines all together and we should
shelve mRNA technology and Lord only
knows what that's Unleashed unleashing
in all of us and everything else but
most people are basically saying okay if
you want the backs have the back so
you're not even you're really not even
saying anything but the the broader
point is that they are still dragging
this guy out and it's not just him right
it's not just Pfizer and NIH and CDC and
fauci and Burks and all of these people
that they still keep putting out there
it's the politicians who got Bamboozled
by them so I hate to do this but I think
it is worth showing again
Donald Trump re-election in 2020 put
this ad out now he's lying every day
about Florida and he's lying every day
about covid vaccines and all of that
stuff so I think it is worth noting it's
not just fouchy who was lying well just
look at this
the president has listened to what I
have said and with the other people on
the task force have said the first and
only time that I went in and said we
should do mitigation strongly the
response was yes we'll do it when He
suggests why don't we do this and I say
no that's really not a good idea from a
scientific standpoint he has never
overruled me the travel was another
recommendation when we went in and said
we probably should be doing that and the
answer was yes when I've made
recommendations he's taken them and then
another time was we should do it with
Europe and the answer was yes he never
counted or overwritten me and the next
time we should do it with the UK and the
answer was yes I never in the multiple
times that I've done that where I said
for scientific reasons we really should
do this that he hasn't said let's do it
the first and only time that Dr Burks
and I went in and formally made a
recommendation to the president to
actually have a quote shut down and
president listen to the recommendation
and went to the mitigation
you know Connor just made a great point
which is that it's a weird ad even if he
was right about all of those things
because at that point it's Trump
basically saying fauci should be
president or fauci was President right
but of course he was wrong about all of
those things but anyway I bring this up
not even to make it specifically about
Trump although Trump has lied about the
response relentlessly as you know the
point is that the swamp
is everybody it's all of these people
right Trump was supposed to be the most
anti-swamp but he handed the keys to the
kingdom to the swamp but of course it's
not just the the health officials like
it's Health officials like fauci or or
the politicians that hand them the keys
to the kingdom it's also the mainstream
media people who push endless nonsense
over and over we haven't showed a video
of this woman in a long time she may be
this is lyanna Wu remember this lyanna
Wu on CNN this woman may have been the
worst of all of the people that
corporate media pushed out to propagate
lies to scare the hell out of you to get
needles into children and lock kids down
and all of the horrible things she may
have been the worst
and we're showing her again so enjoy
I have an almost four-year-old and a one
year one year old I cannot
receive the vaccine I
wearing 4K
Fork especially if we are living in high
transmission areas is still going to be
important and what we really need to do
at this point is to make vaccination the
Easy Choice it needs to be hard for
people to remain unvaccinated I mean we
wouldn't imagine bringing together 20 30
unvaccinated adults putting them in a
single room together the entire day and
have them not wear masks why would we
say that that's okay for our children
travel and having the right to travel in
our state it's not a constitutional
right as far as I'm as far as I know to
um to to board a plane and so saying
that if you want to stay unvaccinated
that's your choice but if you want to
travel you better go get that vaccine I
agree that masks are a very powerful
layer of protection but it's one layer
and if we have so many other layers that
are present masking maybe one that could
go away but we are nowhere near that yet
and I think what we really need to do is
get the vaccines authorized for children
as soon as that's possible
Leanna Nguyen by the way uh she is the
former director of Planned Parenthood
that's an interesting one so she's
really into injecting kids with things
and if she can't kill him earlier than
that she is now the public health
professor at George Washington uh
University which is just really
absolutely insane I guess CNN even got
rid of her but I'm playing all of this
again to show you the theme that there
are these Liars these people that
confuse us and that it's going to keep
happening whether it's war in Ukraine
whether it's covid II whether it's
climate or whatever else and I think
perhaps more importantly than anything
else we must remove these people from
public life who lie about everything who
go against our constitutional rights
there's no constitutional right to being
on a plane like these people are insane
absolutely insane and perhaps you know I
said that she was the worst of all of
them but from a political perspective I
think it's very clear that the worst of
all of our political leaders during
covid was the evil snake person the
lizard man himself Gavin Newsom and
Gavin Newsom is prepping right now to
run for president of the United States
when they push Joe Biden aside that is
that is a fact I don't think that's
conjecture or anything else it is
obviously happening it's obviously in
the works so he was on Meet the Press
yesterday uh and Chuck Todd asked him
about his covid response during covet
um you were pretty strict with the
lockdowns here
and uh it was an interesting piece in
Harper's that sort of
was critic critical of your decisions
from this perspective
you found a way to allow the motion
picture industry and so and the and the
sort of the movie industry to get back
to work but she didn't allow people to
grieve together at funerals or at
churches and that it sort of and that
this may be why there's such a polarized
disconnect what what you prioritize
right this is this anger between the
populace and the elite supposedly here
you prioritize this industry
but you you know you were tougher on
those that just wanted to go worship
um what do you say to that Chris I think
there's a lot of humility and we didn't
know we didn't know and it was hardly I
uh it was we collectively mentioned I
think all of us in terms of our
Collective wisdom we've evolved we
didn't know what we didn't know we're
experts in hindsight we're all Geniuses
so think about what we probably prior
what you ended up collectively
prioritizing your prioritizing industry
one specific one but then didn't
prioritize maybe once it who's maybe
values you didn't connect with I don't
think it's a binary there was iterations
within that theme
Gavin Newsom is the devil he is a truly
evil like there is no other way to
describe it even now he can't fully
apologize now Donald Trump can either
right but Donald Trump is not known for
humility Democrats are supposed to be
nice aren't they what what an evil
now I want to thank him
actually because because of him I moved
my family in two companies and all the
people in this room to the free state of
Florida and our lives were all
flourishing but he has demolished that
state he kept his Winery open he has a
40-acre winery up by Napa he managed to
keep that open while he kept other
wineries closed he locked people in
their houses while he was having dinner
at French Laundry one of the most
expensive restaurants in the United
States with with lobbyists
he is absolutely evil he can't show
Contrition and he can't even put it on
his looks he can't even put it on
himself he's the governor oh it wasn't I
it was we our Collective wisdom well why
did I know plenty of people that did not
want to get vaxxed and that didn't want
to lose their minds and go crazy and I
personally know because I met them at
protests against him people most of whom
were Democrats they were just Democrats
who were mugged by reality who all
become conservatives who who now hate
him and actively were working to get him
recalled and everything else these were
not extremists these were people who
just wanted to live their lives right
and who does this guy go after more than
anyone else well of course he goes after
Ron DeSantis because Ron DeSantis not to
say Ron DeSantis didn't lock down and
everything else in those first few weeks
of covid but as new information came in
he then led the comeback out of the
covid craziness but now Newsome is
spending all damn day trying to take out
to Santa's I want to make one note which
is a bit of a sidebar that Meet the
Press yesterday that was Chuck Todd's
last show ever we covered it a couple of
months back he has officially stepped
down or been fired you never know what
goes on behind the scenes but it is
worth noting that when he took that show
over 10 years ago it was number one uh
in the Sunday talk shows uh it was dead
last as of last week so
anyway what's what else is going on in
California because California is Ground
Zero for the insanity and trust me guys
they want to put it on steroids and
Export it all over the country so this
is absolutely wild this is a guy named
Tony Thurmond he is the California state
superintendent of Public Instruction
and here he is going after parents who
want to know a bit more about what their
kids are learning and whether teachers
are telling boys that they're girls
we want to turn to education for
tonight's newsmaker with book bands and
lgbtq plus students feeling unwelcome in
places across the country one state is
fighting back California the governor
Gavin Newsom and Democrats in Sacramento
they're rolling out new penalties for
school districts that break States rules
among them threatening a 1.5 million
dollar fine to a school district that
refuses to back a state curriculum
mentioning the late California gay
rights leader Harvey Milk investigations
and board Decisions by conservatives new
laws to punish schools that ban books
and just the last week a new lawsuit
against the school district that's
challenging a policy that requires
schools to notify families when a child
says they identify as transgender or use
different names or pronouns one of the
people leading that charge is Tony
Thurman he's California's state
superintendent of Public Instruction and
is exploring a run for governor and he's
joining me now Mr superintendent thanks
for joining us on this appreciate it
um so only a handful of blue states have
taken any direct action against School
boards New Jersey Illinois that is to
name a few none though as aggressive as
California why take these steps now
you know our students are calling out
and asking for help against Mega
extremists who are threatening them
literally threatening them and sadly the
actions of some of the board majorities
in our state are leading to violence
against those who are in the lgbtq plus
community and against students of color
there is so much there I mean first off
the way MSNBC The televised mental
institution the way that they frame that
whole thing but okay fine uh the fact
that this guy they're already teasing
him you can see the way the machine is
going oh we're teasing him as he may run
for governor because you know what oh
that Gavin Newsom guy he's going to be
running for president you can see it
guys like just look through the thing
and start seeing it and then of course
this guy he wants to go after school
boards the better way to be framing that
is you're going against parents parents
are on school boards they're interested
in a little transparency they want to
know what their kids are learning who's
teaching them these things etc etc and
we're gonna find School Board it's 1.5
million dollars if you don't learn about
Harvey Milk I'm guessing that in most of
these schools they don't teach that
Harvey Milk was also having an affair
with a 16 year old boy yeah Google it
for yourself but okay fine fine uh here
he is the same guy they had one of these
school board meetings and the parents
have had it with him and he actually got
thrown out of the school board meeting
which must prove his theory about magic
Maga agreement extremism sure
you'll not bully us here in Chino please
see
[Music]
[Applause]
in Chino
five minute break chaos in Chino as the
state superintendent of Public
Instruction is escorted out of the
public meeting of the board of education
but what I saw here tonight was just
catering to a mob mentality that has
disregard for the safety of many of our
students who are vulnerable and at risk
the emotions explode as the state
superintendent ends his public comment
period bringing a heated exchange with a
school board president as a point of
order as the Border this is not your
meeting you may have a seat because if I
did that to you in Sacramento you would
not accept it please
all this as emotions run high with the
Chino Valley Unified School District set
to vote on a controversial proposal it
would require teachers and School staff
to notify parents if a child identifies
as transgender
even the way that was framed and that
was Fox it's controversial to know if
your kid is being secretly taught that
they're a girl if they're actually boy
that's not that should not be
controversial it's only controversial
because you people keep saying it's
controversial anyway God bless these
parents that there are still a few sane
people in California and by the way guys
Florida is closed you can't come here
anymore uh you go to Texas if you want
you cannot come to Florida something
happened there's like Gators everywhere
it's a real situation uh but no look
joking aside the fact that these that
these parents are stepping up and that
this guy has the balls this guy has the
balls to say oh it's these it's mob
extremists it's the Maga extremist mob
mentality it's parents who are invested
in their own children's current reality
and future you evil freaks speaking of
freaks uh the mayor of Burbank
California got spanked by a drag queen
over the weekend in front of children uh
we're gonna cut the audio on this
because they were playing Macho Man uh
by the Village People and we don't want
to get a strike on the channel but I
think you'll get the point
thank you
I mean do I even have to comment on this
stuff like what is the that's the mayor
of Burbank being spanked all right
uh but let's continue because there is
this
absolutely insane uh bill being passed
in California right now we talked about
it a bit uh in July when it started
working its way through the system and
people were like oh it's never going to
happen and I was like of course it's
going to happen it's Cali there is no
crazy too crazy for California uh but
there is a bill being passed right now
that if you as a parent do not affirm
whatever gender your child says they are
which will most likely be pushed on them
by estate activists masquerading as a
teacher that the state can actually take
your child away and guess what it is
going to pass of course it is going to
pass here is California state
representative Lori Wilson
she is the one who authored this bill
and oh you're not going to believe it
she has a trans child herself what are
the chances and listen to her on why
it's so important to pass this bill that
parents
firm their children they have since the
Donna time
typically it happens when they're
um gender identity expression matches
their biological gender
but what happens is when it doesn't
that's when the affirmation starts to
wane and that's what we're dealing with
here
although it's called the TGI bill
they're not mentioned
anywhere in the law what's mentioned in
the law is the child's gender identity
and expression and the parents
affirmation of that whatever it is
because that is our duty as parents to
affirm our children
that woman is a crazy lunatic and I
don't care if she talks like this to
make it seem like what she's saying is
sensible because it is all Jack
your your responsibility as a parent is
to protect your child to teach your
child truth and hopefully give them the
tools to go out into a difficult world
and have some of the requisite
needs taken care of so that they can get
out there and flourish to the best of
their ability it is not to affirm
everything your child says Justin is now
about 13 months we gave him this little
lion Lulu lion that's what we're calling
him sort of sounds like Lululemon but
we're calling him Lulu lion and now
Justin goes with the lion if one day
five years from now he's six years old
and he says Daddy I'm a lion
they know you are not a lion you are a
small boy pretending to be a lion okay
but then if the government said no we
are putting him in a zoo with the other
Lions this would be a problem but
patience this is going to happen in
California soon enough anyway this
lunatic this woman is a complete and
utter lunatic they are mutilating
children and being applauded as the
tolerant and decent progressives right
uh so she says what she wants at the
hearing about this bill and then a
California Republican comes on and and
he starts talking and you're not going
to believe what happened when he started
telling a little bit of his side of the
story
I want to get this out there this is
important that we know what the science
and the information isn't saying even a
recent follow-up study in 2021 found
that about 139 participants only 17
persisted in their gender identity this
was looking at young boys
122 87 percent went back to their
biological sex you can't have a
state in a point of order
I'm limit on speeches
yes there is
Q assembly member Gallagher
you were given that opportunity thank
you sir all right yeah they cut his mic
he's literally reading a study about
boys converting and then deconverting
de-transitioning whatever you want to
call it and they cut his mic so that is
what's going on in the Banana Republic
of California under the leadership of
Gavin Newsom and the next Gavin Newsom
and everything else but let's continue
on this train ride of insanity because
the most recent jab or shot from the
government is not just about injecting
you his stuff and chopping your kids
genitals off it is directly now going
after the Bill of Rights in this case
the Second Amendment as you probably saw
over the last couple days there is some
crazy I mean this is really crazy stuff
coming out of New Mexico there was a
shooting and now New Mexico Democrat
Governor surprise surprise Democrat
Governor Michelle Lucian Grisham she
wants to suspend the right to carry a
gun
I don't think that's something that she
can do but she said it so watch this all
the examples you cited are crimes kids
shooting at other kids
shooting from Cars so what's the value
of the Civil organ why not just do
better law enforcement both the value of
the order is is that it gives me three
things one it says it's a Statewide
issue and it's a message to everyone to
start leveraging your resources and
arresting people
okay there uh there was a further quote
in there that we couldn't grab you the
video in time but she later went on to
say the amendments to the Constitution
are not absolute uh 100 they are
absolute and we're up against an
interesting thing here because if this
woman believes she can suspend parts of
the Constitution because she has
declared an emergency have you heard
that before they declare an emergency
suddenly our right to assemble remember
that one when they took that away during
kovid now there's some sort of violent
emergency there was a shooting in New
Mexico not to diminish that but suddenly
it's an emergency and now you can't have
concealed carry anymore they cannot
suspend it unless they can and that's
the interesting part that I think we're
going to start coming up against more
and more if we let them and this is why
I always thought covet was sort of a
test for something much bigger if we let
them have their emergency their faux
emergency or even even if it was a real
emergency and then they said boy look at
all the people who actually were willing
to give up their right to peaceably
assemble right they couldn't go to
church they couldn't go say goodbye to
loved ones who were dying they infringed
on our constitutionally guaranteed
god-given rights then why wouldn't a New
Mexico governor and Democrats generally
believe in power grabs right there's no
crisis that they let go to waste why
wouldn't she
suspend the Constitution or tell you
that there's no absolute right if she
can do it knowing that nothing's going
to happen to her so when she says she
can do it in a certain respect she's
right in the most cynical version of it
she's right unless the people rise up
and get rid of these people right vote
these people out of office or put them
in jail or impeach them right I guess
you would impeach someone like that
before putting them in jail but what
does this suspension of our god-given
rights uh because of a tragedy remind us
of right
9 11. so now let's bring this thing back
around I want to show you a video this
is Joe Biden now President Joe Biden or
at least pretending to be President Joe
Biden uh and former Senator John McCain
the day after 9 11 and literally one day
after 9 11 when we had virtually no idea
when the city I mean I can I still I so
vividly like The Reeling the pain the
horror that there were still people
alive that they were going to find over
the next couple days but one day after 9
11 September 12 2001 Joe Biden and John
McCain on TV and guess what they were
pushing for
no it wasn't vax's no it wasn't Shopping
kids genitals off it was the other thing
or
I believe there is absolute resolve on
the part of you for example I was asked
in an earlier program where the American
people use the uh support the use of
ground forces if we determine exactly
what the target was a question my answer
is absolutely yes absolutely yes this is
a unprecedented attack upon the American
people they weren't willing to go the
entire British Army was floating in the
uh in the uh um in the English Channel
and we did not react but once Pearl
Harbor was hit we reacted there's a
fundamental difference you guys don't
get this is in fact an attack upon the
United States American citizens are dead
this is not Bosnia this is not anything
else former President Bush got an
authorization from Congressman there was
an enemy you could identify and there
was a coalition here to go to war so are
we going to declare war against today
well as John McCain said earlier I don't
know who we declare war against that's
why I think the to meet the
Constitutional criteria under the War
Powers Clause of the Constitution you
need only authorize the use of force
I'm sorry we we had a video of McCain
we're not going to put it in there but
he's referencing John McCain I don't
know who we're going to declare war
against do you think there's something
here do you think there is just
something here well I got a little more
for you from that Joe Biden guy and it's
important that we don't forget what
these people have done to this country
in the 22 years since 9 11. that's
probably the best way we can honor the
almost 3 000 people who died not to
mention the hundreds of thousands of
Iraqis who died and I don't know it must
be hundreds of thousands of
afghanistanis and and afghanis and
everything else but here is Joe Biden in
2003 so there's a couple years obviously
after 9 11. defending Democrat Joe Biden
defending Republican George W bush
because in his administration we started
finding out that they basically lied to
us about the Iraq War they lied to us
about weapons of mass destruction and
here's Biden defending the Bush
Administration several senior people in
the administration the president the
vice president made pretty definitive
statements that there were weapons of
mass destruction there you all voted
both you and Senator Luger for war
authorization last October I think based
in part at least on these intelligence
estimates our assessments do you feel
you were misled in any way no look
here's where I start there was a
cataloging of the amount the numbers of
leaders of VX sarenga I mean all the all
these biological or mainly chemical
weapons that was done by the
International Community at the UN under
Mr Butler in 1998 it was clear that
Saddam had these things every member of
the security Council knew it and I think
to the extent that was hyped by some in
the administration it was for public
consumption and try to get public
support because remember that kept
fluctuating it kept fluctuating one day
it would be 48 percent of people and 54
and I think all administrations tend to
do that I remember the first Gulf War we
heard all this about Bay babies being
killed in the Kuwait and the like that
wasn't the reason we went to Kuwait but
it was sort of icing on the cake to deal
with public opinion I think moment shock
and all started from that moment I was
opposed to the effort and I was
outspoken the the rationale was that's
the way to not go to war because I
didn't believe he had those nuclear
weapons I didn't believe he had those
weapons of mass destruction trusted
George Bush to keep his word he said he
was not going to go into Iraq he said he
was only using this to unite the United
Nations to insist we get inspectors in
to see what Saddam was doing okay so the
second part of that that's kind of the
obvious part that now Joe Biden rewrites
history and he's a liar and everything
else but the line in there all
administrations lie it's just icing on
the cake to drum up fear so that we can
get people to go to war until that's the
part you're not supposed to say out loud
now he mumbles things accidentally where
he says things that he's not supposed to
say but back then he still had his
faculties and that he basically was like
oh we tell people there's dead babies
because we need to you know get the
numbers up so we can get to this
freaking War
and that's what they do with everything
and you know what the next thing they
are going to do with it to do with it is
it's climate change it's on the way
lockdowns and everything else get out of
your car don't get in the airplane etc
etc uh the elderly man pretending to be
President Joe Biden was in Vietnam this
weekend and here he is fear-mongering do
you think maybe he wants to get public
opinion up enough so that they can go
ahead and do something about climate
change and the only existential threat
Humanity faces even more frightening
than a than a nuclear war is global
warming going above 1.5 degrees in the
next 20 10 years
and we'll be real trouble
there's no way back from that whoa whoa
whoa I thought white supremacy was the
most existential threat that's what I've
been worried about I wake up every
morning I go we still here because of
the white people they're freaking me out
do you see what they're doing global
climate change and whether the
temperature of the ocean raises a little
bit or any of this you're gonna be okay
it's not to say we can't do some things
on the margins and you can't do little
things in your life to feel better about
the environment or we can't look at ways
to get off fossil fuels and everything
else but you know what if we get off
fossil fuels tomorrow the way these
freaks would like us to we're going to
kill an awful lot of people who need
fossil fuels to stay warm
but do you see it's the same thing they
want which book let me just pull can I
get a poll out of three you guys who's
more afraid of climate change than
nuclear war
nobody nobody yes a nuke dropping a
nuclear disaster how about Russia with
nukes and all of the confusion around
what's going on with Ukraine and if we
got Putin to the end that Putin might be
like all right I'm gonna We got some
nuclear subs around
that is way scarier but so they don't
want you to think that the scary things
are scary and they want you to things
think things that you can have
absolutely no control over
are the scary things and that they can
have no control over like these idiots
could control the weather like their
Cobra from GI Joe in 1984. uh anyway
it's not going well for Joe Biden
because not only is he lying about
climate change obviously uh he also had
a complete brain meltdown mid-sentence
during this press conference and they
actually had to cut him off and bait
well just watch
we talked about we talked about at the
conference overall we talked about
stability we talked about making sure
that the third world the excuse me third
world the uh the the uh the southern
hemisphere had access to changes had
access it wasn't confrontational at all
thank you everybody this ends account
press conference thanks everyone thank
you thank you Vietnam
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I like the cocktail party music like
like they're just like play them off
make people think they're drinking
champagne nobody will notice what's
really going on here like this is so
insane it's ridiculous it really is
we're almost to the to the end guys so
what is the point of all of this the
point of all of this is that there are
lying Liars who do this over and over
again and the themes that they that they
lie about always somehow give them more
power and take away more autonomy
whether it's New Mexico with the guns
whether it's covid whether it's taking
away parental rights related to their
kids whether it's lying us into war
whether it's making you afraid of the
climate instead of nukes all of these
things and it's all because of lies and
not enough of us call out the lies it's
one of the reasons I've been very
critical of trump lately who as you know
I supported last time and obviously I
would vote for instead of Biden but his
endless lying about Florida and DeSantis
and everything else that is not going to
save us either we need people to stop
lying to Jordan Peterson if you decide
to lie you're making the assumption that
escaping scot-free or obtaining an
undeserved advantage will pay off over
the long run all things considered and
you have no evidence for that at all you
know when everyone knows this you can do
something stupid to get out of a jam and
get away with it but the chickens come
home to roost and virtually everyone
knows that so you're going to evince
Faith in one strategy or another or
you're going to lie sometimes and tell
the truth other times and I wouldn't
recommend that at all because all that
does is make you one confused person so
you're playing both ends against the
middle when Christ comes back in the
Book of Revelation he says the worst
form of hell is reserved for the people
who
play both ends against the middle all
right so maybe maybe if we called out
the Liars a little bit more the Liars
who were still in charge right I'm
showing you Joe Biden from 20 years ago
and now he's lying about climate change
now he doesn't even he doesn't even know
what he's saying so I can't even call
what he's doing at this point lies right
it's just muddled in comprehension but
all of the people behind everything
right now they have lied about
everything and nobody seems to pay the
price so I don't know what we all do
with that individually I don't know what
you do with it exactly other than you
can you can
not do it in your own private life you
cannot do it in your personal life you
cannot do it with your friends and
family and again this is how you build
up good Common Sense decent communities
from the bottom up so that one day
you're not living in a place like
California and some administrator is
like oh you didn't affirm what I say
your kid says he is we're literally
taking your children away they will take
your children away in that God forsaken
communist and people will allow
it it is absolutely incredible so look
we were full circle let's do it we were
incredibly United after 9 11. and the
question is is the only way to get to
some feeling
of of being united is it only through
tragedy maybe it is like maybe that's
where we're at as a society right now uh
but maybe not maybe if enough of us
started telling the truth started
pushing the Liars to the margins and
that and that truth became the important
thing right now we're the lies are the
middle the lies are the meat and Truth
is on the margins but how about we
reverse that right how about we flip
that thing on its head then America's
best days can be ahead of themselves can
be ahead of where we're at right now
right it could be tomorrow
instead of yesterday that's the
possibility so now
one more for you uh this is Ronald
Reagan talking about America's best days
and I think
the question is is this what we want or
not it's probably up to us
well I've said it before and I'll say it
again
America's best days are yet to come our
proudest moments are yet to be our most
glorious achievements are just ahead
America Remains What Emerson called her
150 years ago the country of tomorrow
May every Dawn be a great New Beginning
for America and every evening bring us
closer to that shining City upon a hill
can't say it much better than old Ron
can you guys it's me Monday over at the
reubenreport.locals.com community here's
the one that I put up this morning I I
had two posts about 9 11 then we were
just doing something a little silly here
America should accept illegal immigrants
then the guy puts the the pipe in his
own wheel let's establish Sanctuary
cities why should Republicans send
illegal immigrants to us why would
Republicans and illegal immigrants
through us uh if you want to join us for
more of that sort of hilarity
reubenreport.locals.com and uh we leave
you with a cold close this is a little
bit of a A can we call this an AI mashup
I don't want to confuse people and be
sued this is some sort of AI mashup post
game show on the other side see ya we
will be encouraging as I have said
before Americans to get their updated
covid-19 vaccine we know we know that
these vaccines work right we know when
people stay up to date with their
vaccine that works and so that's where I
I'll certainly leave that
[Music]
foreign